>>> THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
CONTINUING HIS CAMPAIGN OF
RETRIBUTION TRYING TO OUST THE
REPUBLICAN HOUSE MEMBERS WHO
VOTED FOR HIS IMPEACHMENT.
HIS HIGHEST TARGET IS LIZ
CHENEY.
AS HE DOES THAT, HE CONTINUES TO
TEASE ANOTHER RUN FOR THE WHITE
HOUSE.
TOP ADVISER JASON MILLER SAYS
THE CHANCES OF HIM ACTUALLY
ENTERING THE RACE AND I'M
QUOTING HERE ARE BETWEEN 99 AND
100 PERCENT.
THE EX-PRESIDENT IS LINING UP
RALLIES IN KEY STATES SCHEDULING
ONE IN GEORGIA AND ONE IN IOWA
AT THE END OF OCTOBER.
ONE PERSON WHO KNOWS HIM QUITE
WELL IS MARY TRUMP, AUTHOR OF
"THE RECKONING, OUR NATION'S
TRAUMA AND FINDING A WAY TO
HEAL."
SHE JOINS US NOW.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON.
YOU SEE THE MOVES BY YOUR UNCLE.
YOU HEAR WHAT HIS ALLIES ARE
SAYING.
DO YOU ACTUALLY BELIEVE HE'S
GOING TO TRY FOR ANOTHER BID FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> I THINK THE CHANCES ARE A LOT
BETTER NOW THAN THEY WERE
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE ELECTION.
HE GOT SO HUMILIATED I DID NOT
THINK HE WOULD PUT HIMSELF IN A
POSITION TO LOSE AGAIN BUT THE
MACHINATIONS OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, VOTER SUPPRESSION BILLS
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO PASS IN
EVERY STATE PLUS THEY'RE WILLING
TO PUSH THAT AND SAYS WE'RE
GREAT PATRIOTS.
IT LEADS ME TO BELIEVE HE MAY
DECIDE THAT IF HE RUNS HE WON'T
LOSE.
HE ALSO HAS A LOT OF INCENTIVE
TO GET BACK INTO THE OVAL OFFICE
BECAUSE IT WOULD PROTECT HIM
FROM THE CRIMINAL CHARGES AND
THE CIVIL CHARGES BEING LEVIED
AGAINST HIM.
>> HE'S RAISED -- YOU KNOW,
BASED ON THE ELECTION LIE, HE
PUT OUT ALL OF THESE FEELERS FOR
MONEY AND A LOT OF PEOPLE SENT
IN A LOT OF MONEY TO HIM THAT HE
CAN USE AS HE WANTS TO -- AS HE
SEES FIT.
>> YEAH.
LISTEN, ANDERSON, THE QUESTION
WILL HE RUN IS UNFORTUNATELY A
RELEVANT ONE AND ONE WE NEED TO
GRAPPLE WITH BUT WHAT IS AN EVEN
MORE QUESTION IS WHY IS HE BEING
ALLOWED TO MAKE THAT CHOICE?
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO INCITED AN
INSURRECTION AND HE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CURRENT
POSITION IS BECAUSE GOVERNORS
LIKE DeSANTIS AND ABBOTT WHO
SEEM TO HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
CONCERN ABOUT THEIR
CONSTITUENTS, PLACE NO VALUE ON
HUMAN LIFE TOOK THEIR CUES FROM
DONALD.
SO WHY IS HE EVEN BEING ALLOWED
TO RUN IF, INDEED, HE DOES?
>> BASED ON YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF
HIM AND YOU'RE A TRAINED
PSYCHOLOGIST, I'M WONDERING WHAT
YOU MAKE JUST OF THE HOLD HE
CONTINUES TO HAVE OVER A VAST
MAJORITY OF REPUBLICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY AND HOW MUCH OF THAT
RELATES -- YA.
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU, THE HOLD
THAT HAS REMAINED?
EVEN THOUGH HE'S BEEN NOT REALLY
IN THE PUBLIC EYE?
YES, OBVIOUSLY HE SHOWS UP ON
FOX AND HE'S STARTED DOING
RALLIES, BUT HE'S BEEN
RELATIVELY SILENT.
>> YEAH, IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME
BECAUSE THE REASON HE'S
CONTINUING TO BE RELEVANT IS
BECAUSE ELECTED OFFICIALS ALLOW
HIM TO BE RELEVANT.
IF ON NOVEMBER 7th THEY HAD
IGNORED HIM AND CONCEDED THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN WON THE
ELECTION, WE WOULDN'T BE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION BECAUSE HE
LIKE EVERY OTHER ONE-TERM
PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE FADED INTO
THE BACKGROUND BUT THEY'RE
KEEPING HIM RELEVANT.
THEY'RE CONTINUING TO EMPOWER
HIM.
THEY'RE CONTINUING TO ASK FOR
HIS ENDORSEMENTS, ET CETERA, ET
CETERA.
SO IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME WHEN,
AGAIN, YOU SEE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS FOLLOWING DONALD'S
PLAYBOOK AND ASKING FOR HIS
POSITION AND CONCEDING
EVERYTHING TO HIM, WHY SHOULDN'T
MILLIONS OF REPUBLICANS WHO
FOLLOW HIM THIS FAR CONTINUE TO
PUT STOCK IN HIM.
>> ACCORDING TO ESPN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HAVE ANNOUNCED HE AND
DONNIE JR. WILL BE PROVIDING
COMMENTARY.
THEY WILL HAVE TO PAY FOR THE
MATCH.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT EXPERIENCE
THEY HAVE.
I DON'T THINK THEY'VE EVER BEEN
IN A FIGHT.
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU EVEN BY HIS
LOW STANDARDS?
IF ANOTHER FORMER PRESIDENT
DECIDED TO SPEND 9/11 COMMENTING
ON A BOXING MATCH ON PAY PER
VIEW, PEOPLE WOULD -- THE HEADS
WOULD EXPLODE.
>> THAT IS, INDEED, THE PROBLEM.
THAT'S BEEN THE PROBLEM ALL
ALONG FOR REASONS THAT ARE VERY
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND.
THERE IS A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
STANDARD -- IN FACT, HE'S HELD
TO NO STANDARD.
IT'S DISGRACEFUL.
IF THERE IS NO BLOW GUN ON THE
RIGHT FOR THIS -- DISGRACEFUL
ISN'T A STRONG ENOUGH WORD TO
DESCRIBE WHAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED, THEN THAT TELLS US
EVERYTHING WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
THE CURRENT STATE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND IT TELLS US
THAT THE DEMOCRATS START --
REALLY NEED TO START WRAPPING
THEIR HEADS AROUND THE FACT THAT
THIS IS NOT A PARTY THAT CAN BE
WORKED WITH, THIS IS NOT A PARTY
THAT SHOULD BE CONCEDED TO.
>> IN YOUR NEW BOOK YOU TALK A
LOT ABOUT TRAUMA.
THE NAME IS IN THE TITLE OF THE
BOOK, THAT'S HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS, DO YOU THINK THAT THAT'S A
WORD THAT DESCRIBES -- IT'S AN
IMPORTANT WORD IN DESCRIBING
AMERICAN HISTORY, MORE IMPORTANT
YOUR UNCLE'S RISE IN 2016?
>> YEAH.
AS I SAY, THIS COUNTRY WAS BORN
IN TRAUMA.
IN THE GENOCIDE BY WHITE
SETTLERS OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION AND GENOCIDE AND
ENSLAVEMENT OF THE AFRICAN
POPULATION.
WE'VE NEVER DEALT WITH THAT.
IT'S BEEN PASSED DOWN GENERATION
TO GENERATION AND IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS WE HAVE DEALT WITH AN
ONSLAUGHT OF ATTACKS AGAINST
IMMIGRANTS, AGAINST PEOPLE OF
COLOR, WOMEN AND ONE OF THE MOST
DIABOLICAL THINGS DONALD DID WAS
DIVIDE THIS COUNTRY AT A TIME
WHEN WE MOST NEEDED TO BE
UNITED.
THAT'S WHEN COVID STARTED.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A VERY, VERY
LONG TIME TO RECOVER FROM THAT,
AS WE SEE, BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO
FOLLOW HIM ARE MAKING IT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET AHOLD OF
COVID, TO GET A HANDLE ON IT, TO
OVERCOME IT.
AND THE VIOLENCE AND THE
RHETORIC VIS-A-VIS MASK MANDATES